>>Student: And in this case,
what we're saying is a section
of this federal wiretapping
act is not constitutional.
>>Narrator: At Urban Academy in New
York City, they don't use textbooks
or standard tests to
teach constitutional law.
>>Teacher: The law doesn't
prohibit them receiving
that information, right?
>>Narrator: Instead, they research
contemporary cases and are graded
on their performance as litigants and
judges in mock trials like this one.
>>Student: -- take it back
to the statute which says,
if you have reason to know that
this was intercepted illegally,
it is illegal to broadcast
or transmit it.
>>Narrator: Urban is itself
at the center of a court case.
At issue is the school's right to
use its own system of assessment,
instead of the state
mandated standardized tests,
called the Regent's exam.
>>Ann: There are thirty-seven schools
across New York state that are part
of a consortium of schools,
public high schools,
that use performance assessment,
instead of high stakes tests,
in order to organize our
curriculum and in order
to determine whether students
are ready for graduation.
>>Teacher: His thesis isn't clear.
>>Teacher: It seems as
though he jumps around.
>>Ann: It's a system of
assessment, not a single instrument,
and it's a system that's based on
a number of components that goes
on all year long, and culminates
in certain kinds of tasks
which we ask students
to do, that demonstrate
that they can actually do something,
they can write research papers,
they can apply mathematical concepts.
>>Student: Basically I was just going
to discuss the current drug
policy in the United States.
>>Ann: So it's really a
good indicator, we believe,
that there's real predictive
validity in the way
in which we approach assessment,
rather than having a high stakes
test, which puts everything
on a single score, and which leads,
we think, to formulaic writing
and doesn't really invest the kids
in any way in what they're learning.
>>Teacher: When I was reading it,
I thought that you have
really excellent ideas.
I just thought that maybe we
could do a little shifting
around of certain things.
>>Ann: We want them to be able
to take text and talk about it,
be able to understand how
to compare different texts,
and to read whole books, not
just little snippets of books.
And we've set them up
with an external assessor.
A lot of these people have got
advanced degrees in literature
or they teach in a university,
or they might write for a living.
Someone who's agreed to spend an hour
with that student, and who then sits
down with that student
and discusses that book
for forty-five minutes or an hour.
>>Student: -- to see whether or
not he saw what she had done.
>>Ann: What we're really trying
to see is, can that student take
that reading and go and talk to
somebody that they don't know,
a perfect stranger, about the book
and have a conversation about it.
That's one way that we can tell
whether a student is ready to go on
and do college level work.
>>Narrator: For many, Urban
represents a second chance,
since most students
come here after dropping
out of other New York high schools.
Yet ninety-seven percent of
Urban graduates go on to college.
>>Teacher: -- a plan
for critical review.
I'm not going to--
>>Narrator: Researchers
believe that the key
to Urban's remarkable success is
its project approach to learning.
>>Rachel: We're sort of
really looking at ways
to engage our students in,
you know, very rich material
that let them figure
things out for themselves,
not give them the pre-digested
textbook account,
but let them read two primary sources
and tease out the complexities.
A lot of it has to do with, I think,
letting the kids encounter
real intellectual material
in all its complexity.
>>Student: But that's the
entire job of the press,
is to print what they deem--
>>Student: What if the
press gets it wrong?
>>Student: Well, then
you should buy your news
from a different press agency.
It's not the job of the
government to decide what's--
>>Mikka: The harm is still done,
whether or not people buy it
from a different press agency.
>>I went to another high school
before I came to Urban Academy,
and we didn't learn anything.
We went through the American
Revolution for the whole term,
and we just sat there and took
notes and we read about it.
>>This is not public education,
it's not of the public interest.
>>But when I came here and
I took constitutional law,
I got to argue things, I got to
understand them more because I had
to defend them and I
had to make my case.
And it really, really makes
you have to think logically.
>>Teacher: I think the solution
to your ending is actually
all on stage already.
>>Narrator: Rather than spending
class time on rote memory drills,
classes like this script writing
workshop foster creativity.
Students even get their
work performed
and critiqued by Broadway actors.
>>Student: And that Dodge
Dart, I see him riding around.
>>Student: Well, maybe
it ain't much to look at,
but that car is my salvation.
>>Student: So?
>>Student: That's my
ticket out of here,
that's my ticket to fame and fortune.
>>Student: How so?
>>Student: I already told
you ten million times.
>>Student: Yeah, but you ain't
never gave me a real answer.
Just a bunch of fairytales
about you becoming a star.
>>Michelle: What happens in the
culture of performance based work is,
young people begin to see their
own intellectual signatures.
They see themselves as the
authors of their own works.
They don't see themselves filling
in other people's blanks, right?
That's not what they do.
They know how to collaborate,
they know how to use experts,
and they know how to
give birth to ideas,
and then find the resources
to develop those ideas.
>>Student: I mean, I like the fact
that we're just paying attention
to the central character--
>>Michelle: To introduce into that
system a test, administered once,
with unbelievably high stakes, that
will feel like an intellectual x-ray,
and will forever tattoo
the mind of young people,
feels like a miseducation
and a kind of social sadism
that backs young people
into leaving schools.
>>Crowd: <chanting> Hey,
no, we ain't no fools.
Take out tests out of our schools.
>>Narrator: In November
of two thousand and one,
the New York Supreme
Court ordered Urban
and the other alternative
assessment schools
to reinstate the Regent's exams
as a requirement for graduation.
But a coalition of students,
teachers, administrators
and parents are continuing
to fight for the right
to set their own standards
of assessment.
>>Jane: We will not allow you to be
reduced to a single test score ever.
>>What's happened is that the
government has sold the people
of this country a bill of goods
that reforming education
means giving a test.
A test was always a measurement,
a form of measurement.
It wasn't a reform tool.
If you want to reform education, you
have to break up these huge schools,
have small settings and really think
about, you know, more money poured
into the schools, more
teacher training,
and come up with novel programs.
Urban is a novel program that works.
Why not look at it if it works?
Why destroy it and try to superimpose
an old system that never worked
for this population to begin with?
>>Ann: I think that what's
happening is, that the decisions
about education are being driven by
the policymakers and the test makers
and the politicians, and not by
the teachers, the professionals.
>>Teacher: On the margins,
he can write a sentence.
What the main idea of this thing?
>>Teacher: That's a good idea.
>>Narrator: There is little
doubt that Urban's system
of performance assessment places
greater demands on its faculty
than administering a standard test,
but there is equally little doubt
that the lessons learned
at Urban will last long
after the Regent's exam
answers are forgotten.
>>Student: I think the interests
of the common citizen here
outweigh the interests
of the corporate media
conglomerates that--
>>Jane: They don't know every
war that's ever been fought
and every river in the world,
but they have depth of knowledge,
and they know how to take an issue
and learn about it and research
and write about it and think
about it and resolve it.
>>I know they have this kind of
education in the private schools.
Every public school
child deserves the same.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.